So how was your golf game today?
You look pretty happy...
...it must have gone well.
You wouldn't believe me if I told you.
Try me.
What happened?
I got a hole in one.
I'm still shocked.
I can't believe it!
What? A hole in one?
You're joking!
Nobody gets a hole in one!
I'm totally serious.
I wouldn't joke about something like that!
Wow! Congratulations!
That's absolutely amazing!
You know, most pro golfers go their entire career without acing a hole.
I know.
I'm still shaking!
Well, I think this calls for a celebration.
Let's go have a few drinks.
On me, of course!
Sounds great!
I could use one about now.
So what was the hole you did it on?
It was the 16th hole;...
...par three, 175 yards.
I used a 9 - iron.